[Music]
so let's go to alicia in spearfish south
dakota hey alicia what's up
hey dr john how are you
i'm hey i'm almost in a diabetic coma
after how many thin mints i've eaten
today but i'm doing great how about you
oh i'm good a little nervous they're
super excited to be talking to you today
hey listen
100 chance you're better at this than i
am so you have nothing to be nervous
about i'm nervous so how can i help
what's up
yeah okay so
um i have been married for 10 years
and in
2019 my husband came forward
and admitted to a sexual addiction that
had been going on
our entire
relationship and
through a lot of intensive therapy and
just
a lot of
other counseling we
have an amazing marriage right now we
just
he's my best friend and
my safe person and we've done a lot of
hard work to get there
but um right now
we are um
thinking about
getting our story out there more
publicly like through our church and um
all of our close friends and family know
but we
feel like we should
tell our children
before
this gets out we live in a fairly small
community and we would hate for
them to find out
by someone else
so when
when and how is the best way to go about
telling them our story sounds like this
is a remarkable story of
bravery and honesty and
redemptions that's
you
alicia are incredible um so walk me all
the way to the beginning here um so you
all dated for a while i'm assuming and
then you were married for 10 years
i hear a lot of the phrase sexual
addiction and
it
usually isn't
but sometimes it is
what when you say sexual addiction walk
me through what was your husband
experiencing or what was he doing
yeah it started out with pornography and
then
strip clubs then shady massage parlors
and then up to prostitution okay
and was this interfering with
your finances he was sneaking around i
mean this became a
way of life
yes i had no clue um and yeah he spent a
fair amount of money on it
it i did not notice it um
just
because it
in the realm of our income it didn't
make a huge
dent but um a few
thousand dollars worth
um
between
that ten-year
well probably a five-year span i would
say
so walk me through he sits down and
unpacks this for you
tell me about that day
um he came forward
to me saying that he was struggling with
a pornography addiction and
again i was blindsided i was really hurt
by that
and after a few days of processing i had
a few questions
about that and
at the i had about no probably 10
questions to ask him regarding the
pornography and then
at the end i said i know this is a
ridiculous question but i just i have to
know have you ever cheated on me
and i mean we were watching the office
it was a friday night and i was not
expecting the answer that i got
and
wow
what a moment to ask a shape-shifter
question right
yes like i said i was not expecting i
was expecting to be reassured and
it just all came crashing down and
unfortunately my oldest daughter at the
time heard me freaking out and
um
my husband tried to like calm her down
and send her back down to her room to go
to bed and
but it was our pastor came over and one
of my best friends came over to
help be with us
in that moment
but yeah it was very true it's a
traumatizing time yeah and so what has
happened over the last
couple of years
to
help heal
you your marriage i mean ten years of of
dishonesty and betrayal is a long time
what has happened in the last two years
to have you speaking so highly of him
well i was
he had been pretty emotionally
disconnected our whole marriage which
makes sense now but um
so when he told me this i was ready to
file for a divorce and you know i
i couldn't get an attorney to call me
back so i agreed to go to
counseling with him because he really
wanted to
make it work
and so
yes did like
a few weeks of intensive therapy in a
different state and
and you know he never once
um
blamed me
he took full and complete ownership
and i just saw
so many
tears from him and
he let me
yell and
scream and he just would say i know you
deserve so much better and
he
um just put a lot of things in place
he's been in several accountability
groups and
um
and he actually set up consequences for
himself when he would
um if he were to even say a white lie he
would
sleep on the floor at night and or drink
a cup of pureed broccoli because that
was something he wanted to fix in
himself
so he was very determined to sober up
and
the way he's been with our children has
just been incredible um
so can i ask you can i ask you a
deeply personal question
sure
um and you may have heard me talk about
this on this show
one of the most common things i hear
from folks who are in a relationship
where there's cheating
is
that the rage and the anger and the
mistrust and all that
but deeper than that more painful than
that or more maybe not more painful but
more disorienting than that
is that i shared a bed with a guy for 10
years and i missed it
i didn't know
and it i
i'm crazy like i feel crazy how in the
world do you miss your husband with
prostitutes and with
you know massage parlor trips and how
did i miss thousands of dollars right
and you start backtracking it it's
almost like uh watching fight club for
the first time and you realize oh i
missed the whole movie all right or uh
the sixth sense or something right so
how did you feel
are you just are you good
if you are you you need to bottle that
up and sell it because that's incredible
well
i still struggle with that whenever i
get
a little uncomfortable with
a situation if
he has to go out of town overnight
somewhere
um i i yeah i do still
struggle with that but um not it gets so
much easier
as more trust is built okay there you go
and he yeah he's just been
very open and honest with
yeah whatever
i need to look at he's
willing to give it to me awesome so he's
he's he's doing his best to live a
transparent life which lets you breathe
a little bit right
yes it's awesome
all right so here's a how old are your
kids
i have a seven
four and nine month old
okay
so tell me about this decision to
be public with this story
what are y'all thinking yeah
i
uh my eyes have just been open to how
big of a problem this is and
um
and i've had
friendships who have had struggling
marriages with
husbands who have gone outside the
marriage
and
i just
want to be able to provide a sense of
hope that
um
it
can work out if you make it
if you put in the work for it sure
so um my my rule of thumb and this is
going to be different um and again i'm
not basing this on any research that
i've read so let that would be clear
this is coming just from me
my rule of thumb is
is however long a thing went on
is how long you wait until you start
telling that story publicly
and here's here's a couple here's a
couple things to think through
it's generally it's with
folks who struggle with drug abuse
or folks who struggle with financial
issues
that the moment they get
clean
for any any period of time
they want to go tell everybody about it
and what i've seen over and over and
over again and this isn't your story so
don't hear me talk about into your story
and i'll give you some context for i
think for your situation specifically
is
you can end up taking people with you
the second time
if you have a relapse if something goes
wrong if something gets off the tracks
and
i want to see people be whole and well
before they start so for me i was
buried with anxiety i was buried with
nonsense i didn't treat people right it
was a decade ago
and now i'm becoming i'm talking about
it publicly now i'm writing books about
it now i'm speaking about it because
i've got a decade's worth of healing
underneath me does that make sense
uh yeah and when the attacks come
when people write me and say you're full
of crap you misinterpreted this research
i think what you're saying is nonsense
and i've had some prominent people in
the country really challenge me on some
stuff we got toe to toe and
on some hard stuff right
and i've had equal support too so it's
not like it's just raining but if i
hadn't had this long of healing if i
wasn't this secure and what i think and
what i know and i didn't spend this much
time in the research and the literature
all that
those things would decimate me and
inadvertently send me right back to
where i was now it may not be a sexual
addiction like in your case
but addiction will find its way out in
other places it may even be and it's
going to sound crazy
addiction to transparency
anything that i'm holding on to as a
crutch to get through a hard season or a
boring season or tiring season
ends up being an addiction that doesn't
mean you guys wait 10 years
okay
here's what i think
you guys can do
we had a
we regularly my wife and i
almost oh i mean gosh sometimes every
week
um this past weekend had a couple from
out of state working on some stuff
working through some stuff
um came and stayed with us thinking
through some things
that happens all the time and the um the
work that my wife especially she's just
so gifted
but that we do behind closed doors with
people that nobody ever ever knows
that ends up being legacy shifting or
shape-shifting and it's not that we're
doing all the work but we're providing
space and some encouragement and some
wisdom and some walk alongside yep did
that too been there too
um
that
it doesn't need to be spoken publicly if
you are a resource and a caring
person caring couple in that way
man you will find yourself inundated
with people who want to talk to you
behind closed doors how your friends
showed up for you in the middle of the
night
you could do that for 10 years and no
one would ever know on instagram that
you're doing this
and you are saving hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of marriages just by your
presence just by your willingness to
speak
and eventually that becomes hey i'd like
you to come talk to my group like
whatever i went and spoke to celebrate
recovery group i'm gonna talk to a
church group i'm gonna whatever that is
hey would you come talk to our group or
at work hey we'd love for you to talk
about this but there's a way to lean
into this without
i wish i had another way to do it
without getting famous for it
okay yeah it's so easy to to jump from
the crazy story to we should write a
book
um here's a simple example in my house
my son when he was born my wife was a
um she was a nationally recognized
researcher when it came to child
literacy i'm teaching teachers how to
teach kids how to read she was a savant
and then my little boy comes along and i
have a phd in higher education i spend a
lot of time in student development and
childhood development that's just what i
did that's what she did
our son was incredible
temperament wise
um attitude wise he just was a great
easy kid
he was really articulate he could speak
well he could read at a young age and
there came a moment when he was i don't
know four or five i'll never forget the
arrogance what a [ __ ] i was and i
looked at my wife and said
i think every other parent is an idiot
this isn't hard if you are incredible
and brilliant like the two of us
and she probably rolled her eyes but i
didn't pay attention because i was too
arrogant back then and i said we didn't
quit our jobs and good on the road and
write a book about how to be a great
parents
and then we had my daughter
same parents
same same geniuses
just a totally different human
and my daughter's incredible and she is
a human hurricane in all the best ways
we have no business writing
writing books on this right now right
and so i tell you that to tell you this
i would slow down you're talking the
healing here is three years two years in
a little bit of time
for a decade or 12 or 15 years of
betrayal
that's still relatively raw
when it comes to talking with your kids
seven four and you know obviously not
the nine month old seven and four
that's real young to sit down and say
hey mom's mommy and daddy are gonna go
talk about all the stuff we did or the
stuff that happened to us and what daddy
did and
um
maybe your seven-year-old could have a
context there but it would have to be
very high level very age-appropriate
um no seven-year-old's gonna understand
massage parlors or prostitutes
or um
they would understand daddy made some
really big mistakes and it hurt mommy a
lot
and now daddy's um
changed and he has really grown hard and
mommy has forgiven him and when y'all do
have that conversation you're holding
hands you're seeing each other you're
smiling
and
because as soon as you talk about that
fracture
that kid's body is going to go into
fight or flight oh no
right
and
i'll be very very careful and very slow
age-appropriate introducing that stuff
what happens a lot in this situation is
parents want to absolve themselves of
what they're carrying around and the
kids are not strong enough to carry it
so don't tell them because you feel like
we just got to be honest with everybody
bro like they can't handle it it's too
heavy
right
as they get older
and
they make you have high school kids now
you're talking you can sit down and have
some harder conversations maybe even
middle school again but we're all
talking very age-appropriate
when i would actually sit down and say
hey son or daughter i got to talk to you
about some stuff i did when you were
before you were born
um
i mean you're talking
junior senior in high school maybe even
later maybe in college like i got some
stories i got to tell you um here's what
kind of jerk i was and here's how sick i
was for a season
um that makes sense i feel like i'm
bursting your bubble here and i know you
guys have a heart of gold and want to
help other people
um i i what i really want is i want you
all to be wise and i care way more about
your marriage right now
and your three little ones than i do a
story or a book that can be written
does that make sense absolutely yes i
totally respect that and
um i guess i'm it's more about when to
tell the kids who i'm afraid if we don't
if
like if we wait until they're in high
school or
college age are they going to be really
mad that we kept this from them let me
feel even more what would it be
no what does it gain them if you lie to
them yes
if one of them ever asks you in middle
school when they get cheated on the
first time
you don't even know what this is like if
this never happened to you has it and
you can say oh honey i got a story to
tell you
right if you lie to your kids that's
where resentment comes from
choosing not to burden your kids with 10
years of infidelity and 10 years of
prostitutes and massage parlors that's
big time when your husband and you sit
down to have the talk about pornography
which i've had both of my kids now six
and 12 right
when that y'all have that conversation
you could talk about hey there's some
hard things uh but there's stuff i'm not
talking to my son about yet and i'm real
real open with him
he's not there yet he's not there yet
and so one day we'll get there one day
we'll have some harder conversations or
some deeper conversations i'll tell them
about some of our friends that he knows
and loves some of our community members
and family members that he knows and
loves
but right now i'm more focused on
telling him the truth
than i am lying to him
does that make sense
absolutely okay in a radically honest
house like you have now
don't let that don't don't
hand your kids bricks of truth if
they're not strong enough to carry it
okay
that's fair easily i can definitely do
that but i don't i don't want to burden
them with
with that if it's not going to help them
can i tell you this
you're a great
mom
like thank you no no you just you gave
me the
which is your way of dismissing things
you're a great mom
you're a great mom
and
there's a season of doubt that's still
here that's normal it's it'll take years
to heal
and you're not crazy and this guy won
the lottery
with you
absolutely won the lottery
and
outside of the the challenges infidelity
the way you talk about him sounds like
you won the lottery with him too
and i definitely did so you all are
going to continue to grow and heal
together and you're going to create
something masterful that will bless a
bunch of people i want to see you bless
people behind closed doors for a season
quietly through relationship over the
over a kitchen table with meals
nobody ever knows in and out
and get good at that
get honest with that continue your
healing journey with yourself and with
your husband
and man then the book will come one day
the big story and the big reveal that
will happen one day
i would just let that play itself out a
little bit longer